a common unspoken rule of Commander is
that people should get to have a game
plan to do a thing to do their thing and
on the surface this makes a lot of sense
it's a casual format and people are here
to have fun in other casual multiplayer
games Universal participation is
understood to be a core tenant and steps
are taken to ensure that all players get
to play a part in a role playing game
like DND or Pathfinder you don't want to
let a player be a wizard only to then
have them spend the entire campaign in
places with some mysterious anti-magic
field that's not ideal gameplay so
broadly it's understandable that
Commander Echoes this understanding and
even allows players 100 cards worth of
expression in how they play the game
this is all fine and good but what's
easy to forget is that Commander is a
multiplayer offshoot of a generally
two-player game an offshoot that didn't
always exist the fact that the format
has a higher life total than 60c card
1v1 formats is intentional it works to
make space for decks that would
otherwise struggle there are a lot of
potential creative strategies that
simply can't hold up in a 20 Health
format attacking people with creatures
early is just a bit too good in this way
Commander's 40 starting Health itself
serves as a buil-in do the thing enabler
no extra effort needed from players this
higher life total was intended to
accomplish a task and it did so
admirably however over time it has
accomplished a lot more than just this
I'm getting ahead of myself though
Commander has basically grown up with
this identity of being a slower form
rout where a more laid-back form of
magic can be played this is reflected in
the Mana curves of a lot of the original
precons zany high cost stuff is a staple
feature of the format and these sorts of
cards are often core pillars of their
respective decks there are a couple
Frameworks we could use to think about
how EDH decks compared to decks in a 60c
card 20 Health format one is the turning
point of a given game basically if we
separate each game into a buildup phase
where players are preparing and a climax
phase where players are starting to
perform whatever action will win them
the game roughly when is there a
transition in a lot of classic 60 card
decks this turning point is quite early
Delver decks look to land a turn one
threat and gradually chip down opponents
and other decks like jund similarly look
to land early threats in contrast to
this most Commander decks spend the
first several turns of the game ramping
setting up engines tutoring and starting
to piece together Synergy packages a big
piece of this likely comes down to life
totals 40 life means that a threat needs
to be larger to pose a risk to opponents
whereas in Legacy a single Mana can be
spent on a deck's win plan followed by a
long sequence of turns spent purely
defending that plan and suppressing a
player's opponent a much larger Mana
investment is necessary to break through
40 life without the help of an infinite
combo in addition even if a deck defeats
a single opponent there are still two
opponents at the table so it's often
wise to invest an even greater amount of
Mana up front to formulate a threat that
can subdue two or more players in Rapid
succession the fact that larger
Investments are needed to win games
means that draw and ramp are almost
Necessities plans will involve lots of
cards that don't directly contribute to
winning a game this is another point of
contrast between commander and 60c card
1v1 formats in a burn deck and ever
popular archetype in 60 card formats a
majority of a deck will often be spent
on the task of reducing opposing life
totals though you could point to control
decks as spending less deck space on
Direct wincons these decks still use
cards like removal and draw to build up
to the dominant game State they need to
be in to win a lava Spike performs a
similar role for an aggro deck as an up
the bean stock does for a control deck
and this comes down to the fact that
different decks are different if we
focus on ramp removal and draw as
categories of card a large portion of
decks in 60 card formats exclude one two
or even all three of these things which
is notable when you consider that
basically all Commander decks are
expected to have all of these things
this is also in spite of the fact that
Commander decks have access to well a
commander an additional card that is
available at all times a permanent
eighth card in hand a lot of people fail
to acknowledge how incredible that is a
deck could easily pick out a commander
that mostly fulfills a particular role
to allow their deck to focus Less on
that but this isn't generally what
happens taking a look at some popular
recent commanders is mostly payoff or
escalation of some kind when a thing
happens either more of that thing or
something different happens a lot of
commanders will draw cards in some form
or or other but these decks will then
still include a lot of card draw these
features paint a specific picture of
Commander as a format decks are expected
to run decent quantities of ramp and
draw because they're expected to be
bigger taller than decks in 60 card
formats and this is facilitated by
having more cards and more Mana this
much is unsurprising on some level these
attributes are encoded into the very DNA
of the format however over time this DNA
has Twisted and metastasized into an
increasingly homogeneous version of the
format one where decks are expected to
look a certain way decks have grown
bigger and taller over time they gain
more mana and draw more cards than decks
in the past did the funny thing about
ramp and draw is that they have an
amplifying effect while a Windon or a
removal spell won't generate more of
those things ramp gives Mana to cast
more ramp spells and card draw finds
more card draw as more and more powerful
draw engines have been printed over the
last 10 years along with the EDH
developing a more streamlined deck
building culture Decks that Focus
heavily on draw and ramp have become
more and more prevalent in tandem with
this deviant from this version of
Commander has become increasingly
challenging from a social standpoint
when players see opponents doing some
sort of tall game plan one deck building
reaction could be to go under it this is
common in competitive 1v1 formats you
play aggro to rip away your opponent's
life total while they're still in the
setup phase of their greedy nonsense you
play combo to take advantage of them
ignoring you you play Stacks piece pces
to clamp down on specific play patterns
all of this is possible in some form or
other in Commander you can play Voltron
or group slug you can play combo and you
can play Stacks pieces the issue is
these things are often considered rude
at a lot of midow EDH tables it's UNC to
see your opponent doing some greedy
nonsense and to then try to cramp down
on it the polite counterplay is to go
bigger to get more mana and more cards
and escalate harder Commander as a
casual format has the awkward Dynamic
that there isn't a metag game per se and
everything that happens is basically
moderated by a giant glob of
expectations that players and their
opponents decide on verbally or
otherwise while certain plays might not
be explicitly disallowed there will be
varying levels of social acceptance of
various different options a player could
decide on these social pressures then
reinforce themselves as different
players enter and exit the format under
these new conditions if a player base
decides that Armageddon is unacceptable
well winter is almost as bad and Gad
Teague is a bit too staxy as well and
archon ver Maria also constricts player
agency doesn't it and I don't know about
poison counters and Commander damage
either those seem pretty sus as well as
counter measures become less and less
widespread players will feel more and
more emboldened to chase big greedy
decks to their logical end point as
snowballing mid-range decks are allowed
to become a more and more dominant part
of the EDH landscape they become all but
synonymous with the format they become
the way to play casual Commander now I
don't want to necessarily say that this
is inherently a purely bad thing I have
multiple Decks that are absurdly tall or
absurdly greedy and I've also made decks
with the explicit intent of being taller
than other decks the dominance of tall
Commander means that players are able to
do big expressive plays with a wide
degree of Freedom it means that new
players are allowed to explore the
format without getting immediately
pressured down by decks built with the
intent to kneecap slower and greedier
decks any given deck's thing might take
more or less time than any other deck's
thing and allowing the most of these
things to happen involves pushing back
the point at which decks begin to focus
on closing out games letting decks focus
more on the buildup stage if the goal is
to accommodate the most of these and
allow the most people to do the most of
their thing tall EDH is really the only
way to go however it's worth keeping in
mind that this form of Commander isn't
without issues all of its own one issue
with the gradual upward race of tall
Commander is something I spent an entire
20-minute video on a couple months ago
information overload EDH boards are
wildly complex these days while 60c card
1v1 formats feature the relatively
simple board state of two players EDH
features the board states of four
players board states that are often far
more complex than ones that would be
found in 60 card formats as a result
players in a game of Commander need to
process a lot more different cards than
players in a 60 card format and doing so
will use Mental energy that could be
spent on planning turns strategizing
politicking or performing Alternative
forms of threat analysis this will
naturally fall hardest on newer players
who are familiar with fewer cards and
thus need to take more time to process
the cards being played in a game some of
this added information is inherent to
Commander as a format having four
players is kind of baked into how we do
things here in edhv and having a massive
30-year long card pool is likewise a
fact of life Commander is unavoidably
going to be more complicated than 60
card formats and that's just kind of the
price of Entry it was originally
popularized by judges after all what's
not a fact of life is everybody playing
these big escalatory mid-range piles
with each deck developing more and more
utility or value permanence over the
course of a game each with probably way
too much text commander is inherently
complex but it doesn't need to be this
complex big complex board States paired
with Decks that want to perform
exponentially more actions as a game
progresses lead to an additional problem
turn lengths casual EDH games have a
reputation for being mercilessly long at
times and I'd argue a Lion's Share of
this is due to Long turns long games
aren't always a bad thing I've had
multi-hour back and forth grinds that
were genuinely exciting however when
turn length is the primary cause of a
game's length things are rarely this
enjoyable one of the issues is that long
turns beget long turns if the game's
turns are a sequence of back-to-back 5
to 10minute fiddle fests other people
are going to start chatting or checking
their phone or gazing off into space
then when it does get back around to
somebody's turn instead of planning
ahead for it their mind has been
wandering and they need to recalibrate
on what they'll be doing increasing how
long their turn takes this cycle reminds
me of some of the Less Pleasant D andd
encounters I've partaken in and it's a
cycle that can really take a toll on the
goal of maintaining a dynamic game of
EDH the issue of long turns and thereby
long games then ends up increasing the
social acceptability of more aggressive
strategies this pattern is most clear
with Voltron an archetype that involves
putting a bunch of ores or equipments on
a particular creature and then defeating
opponents with it one by one but it
really applies to focusing down
opponents in general despite the fact
that strategically it might be correct
to fully Focus down a particularly scary
player this is somewhat unpopular in
part because of how long EDH games go if
knocking out a player meant them sitting
around for 10 or 20 minutes for the game
to finish I doubt most people would have
too big of an issue with that however
when it means sitting around for 45
minutes or even an hour while the
remaining players fiddle around with
their fussy Boards of snowball mid-range
it's a bit less ideal in addition to the
other issues I've mentioned the current
Commander landscape is one that favors
board wipes quite heavily players will
put together these wild snowbally
packages that explode out of control in
a matter of turns and when there are
multiple of these sorts of decks with
taboos against stacks and aggro the only
option is to board wipe and to board
wipe frequently the collateral damage of
this will be the players trying to
advance their own game plan at a normal
Pace trying to gradually build up
something of their own this is the
Paradox of doing the thing the form of
Commander that gives players the most
time to develop a slower game plan is
the exact same form of Commander that
cultivates board wipes as this constant
and unavoidable Factor you get to do the
thing and I sure hope you liked doing
that thing because you're going to get
to do it about five more times after
after getting board wiped repeatedly so
those are some of my problems with the
state of Commander as it currently
exists this wildly tall version of the
format and a natural follow-up question
might be can those problems be solved in
a way that improves the format I
mentioned the taboos against shorter
strategies such as aggro and stacks and
I know some of you probably thought to
yourselves but Alex even without taboos
aggro simply isn't a viable strategy in
casual Commander is this true kind of
yes but also kind of no
it's true in the sense that if you pull
out an aggro deck against three snowb
mid-range decks the table will likely
get annoyed at you and beat you into
submission it's almost considered rude
at a lot of EDH tables to introduce life
total into the game as a relevant Factor
before people have generated a bunch of
value in whatever way their particular
deck likes to do such a thing however
the fact that games so often involve
nothing but snowbally value decks isn't
some kind of set in stone fact of life a
good counter example to the current
state of Commander is a pool of $25
decks I play played with a few years
back that pool had some pretty tall
decks a simic toolbox mid-range deck and
a gr big Mana deck come to mind however
the tallness of these decks was
modulated by the diversity of the rest
of the pool the pool had four faster
Decks that would put on pressure as well
as a couple control Decks that could
punish overextensions from any other
deck the result of this was that all
slower decks needed to build in tools to
hold off aggro blockers life gain early
removal and so on likewise all of the
mid-range decks in the pool needed to
include tools for maintaining a game
plan through the unrelenting grasp of
the pool's control decks this little
meta game resulted in well-rounded and
resilient decks when the situations a
deck is likely to end up in are more
specific and dramatic than simply facing
a squishy blob of generic mid-range
those decks need to be built in a way
that adapts to that rather than just
following a formulaic plan every game
the other thing this pool did was
guarantee deck diversity in games since
decks were selected randomly from a pool
of 10 the average four pod deck pool
would have two faster mid-range decks
one slower mid-range deck and one
control deck even in games where slower
decks were represented more heavily a
singular faster deck in the Pod could
still usually do just fine the slower
decks were somewhat diverse and none of
them were Allin on a snowbally game plan
because doing this would likely lead to
getting destroyed in any game with more
than one fast deck the randomization
also had the side benefit of forcing
players into playing all decks and
experiencing all sides of things which
gave greater insight into how to play
strategically something funny is that
the Groll big Mana deck the greediest
deck in the pool and decidedly mid-pack
in terms of win rate ended up feeling
the strongest outside of the pool by a
long shot its weakness within the pool
was other decks pressuring it down
knowing it would pop off in the late
game but in the general Commander
ecosystem people play slower decks and
don't have the same built-in
understanding that a late game deck is
one that should be attacked early and
often it's rude to throw your creatures
at the snowball opponent turn after turn
you'd better spread out that damage
they're just trying to do their thing
after all if you want to hear more about
this specific Dynamic my friend the
trinket Mage just released a video that
dives into the question of whether to
allow decks to do their thing and a link
to his video is in the description now
does any of this information provide a
solution to the issues I have with tall
decks well not exactly but it's a useful
window into how formats get
conceptualized by the people who play
them I'd encourage players to give
building their own deck pool a as
navigating a little meta game can be a
lot of fun and is a type of fun that
Commander players usually miss out on
however most commander games will
continue to feature unpredictable
combinations of decks likewise having
Decks that deviate from the snowball
mid-range mold can be quite fun but
generally you need to have at least two
deviating decks in a game to really
break out of the conventional mold for
my part I'm in my aggro era over the
summer I revamped my liasa ha Bears deck
to have a bit less stacks and some
additional tools for beat down and value
generation and it's been a lot of fun to
be threatening life total more
consistently I'm also tinkering with a
handful of other Decks that can put on a
healthy amount of pressure while still
fitting nicely into a typical EDH game
including an updated version of the
malagor deck from the $25 pool obviously
you shouldn't make it a goal to ruin the
fun of other players some players do
this and they should stop but I'd argue
it's perfectly fine to at least push
other players out of their comfort zone
a bit EDH is a game not an art pallet or
a drawing cards simulator and though the
increased 40 life is nice for allowing a
greater diversity of slower decks it's
also valid to treat opposing life totals
the way they're treated in other formats
a thing that wins you the game if you
reduce it to zero there is no one right
answer to how to navigate a social
format like EDH and people should
largely be allowed to play what they
want to play We Should however give
faster and more suppressive Decks at
least a portion of the leeway given to
the Synergy Blobs of the world a more
vibrant and dynamic format is a thing
worth pursuing thanks for watching and
thank you to architect for supporting
the channel I've been using architect
for years and the UI is so crisp and Nic
looking that I've been using architect
screenshots in videos going back months
before they were even giving me money
you can check out all of my decks down
at the link in the description I also
want to thank my patrons for supporting
the channel if you want to join them you
can go over to
patreon.com snail finally if you want to
pick up some cards for that new Stacks
deck you just got inspired to build I
left a TCG player affiliate link down in
the description I've found TCG player to
be the best place out there for buying
lots of cheap cards in one Fell Swoop
which has been helpful for all the
budget decks I've bought over the years
all right that's all bye now